do you see what this chart looks like
okay this is the balance sheet
of the federal reserve go to 2008
and look where we were you see the
straight line we were less than a
trillion dollars is what we were okay
when we're just printing money the
balance sheet what did they do in 2008
like 2009
boom we go to two trillion dollars you
see two million here on the side it's
because you got to add another million
to it but total assets is in trillion so
we went from less than a trillion
to two trillion and then in 2013 we went
from two and a half three trillion to
four trillion and then we stayed at
around four trillion and we did a little
bit of quantitative tightening
and uh uh
and then you have a little bit we didn't
do corner tightening that the
number that was rolling was still around
four trillion dollars and then covet
hits and where do we go from four
trillion
we go from less than four trillion
to five trillion to six trillion
to seven trillion to 8 trillion to now 9
trillion
look at the spike
you tell me how much this spike
matches this spike
this was a small spike and in gradual
this is a sudden spike because we've
been printing money and now the
government says wait a minute we gave
the economy too much money we got to
take money back have you ever had a kid
your kid that you gave too much
allowance and you told them i'll give
you a thousand two thousand dollars of
allowance if you go and get a job
and you realize you made a mistake of
giving the allowance prior to the kid
getting a job
so you wait a month he's not even
applying for any jobs you wait two
months he keeps telling he's applying he
ain't applying and if he's got job
interviews he's not doing good
interviews intentionally to not get the
job because he's getting free money from
you why would he work that hard
and then all of a sudden you lose it you
have a conversation with your husband
with your wife and you say babe we got
to cut that allowance and you go to your
son and he says son
daughter guess what that two thousand
dollars is gone figure it out
what happens
the overreaction what happens i can't
believe you're doing this i can't
believe you're doing that how am i going
to get a job
we're about to go through that because
many of these too big to fail companies
been constantly bailed out it's okay we
got your back it's okay we got your back
and if they stop doing that there's
gonna be some problems you see today on
the podcast we talked about four things
that makes capitalism work and here's
what it is capitalism works when we have
the freedom to buy whatever we want to
buy legally freedom to sell whatever we
want to sell legally
freedom to choose whatever we choose in
capitalism but also freedom to fail one
more time freedom to buy freedom to try
freedom to
freedom to buy freedom to self freedom
to try
freedom to fail
the last part has disappeared since 2008
because we keep bailing people out if
they're going this direction
if they actually stick to it what
they're trying to say is we're gonna
allow some of these guys to fail let's
see if they're gonna stick to that or
not okay we're gonna allow some of these
bigger guys to fail and by the way no
one ever thought lehman brothers was
going to go out of business no one ever
thought merrill lynch is going to almost
go bankrupt until bank of america came
and bailed him out no one ever thought
woman was going away people that woman
was going to beat b of a in wells fargo
chase bought him for 1.9 billion nobody
thought new century was going out of
business you know how many countries but
do you remember countrywide no one
thought these guys would you keep
country-wide they're not going anywhere
what happened to them
this is where we are today and
quantitative tightening is coming so now
i just explained this part and now
you'll be able to explain this to other
people because it's a simple way
to explain it remember earlier when i
showed you the correlation between
interest rates and inflation watch this
here this is the correlation
between the balance we have on the
federal reserve which is eight trillion
dollars and s p 500. isn't it
interesting that they're pretty much
picture perfect the same thing
how weird is it
so you put the money into the market and
the market goes up huh so if they take
money out of the market what happens to
the market market's going to go down
that's how the money works if this
correlates and they do quantitative
tightening
markets going to go down so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]